the thing about it me and Adidas is like
I could literally say anti-semitic and
they can't drop me well they just did
Adidas has officially decided to cut
ties with Kanye West I could say
anti-semitic things and Adidas can't
drop me
now what
now what the sportswear company
announced the news in a statement
Tuesday saying it does not tolerate
anti-Semitism and any other sort of hate
speech they call Kanye's recent comments
unacceptable hateful and dangerous and
add that after a thorough review they've
decided to immediately end their
partnership with yay Adidas said the
rapper's comments violated the company's
values of diversity and inclusion mutual
respect and fairness
this all comes after yay tweeted earlier
this month that he intended to go Defcon
3 on Jewish people a post that led to
his social media accounts being
suspended but Kanye doubled down
delivering an anti-semitic rant in a
since deleted episode of the drink
Champs podcast the Jewish media was
pushing the narrative off the White live
White lives matter t-shirt that I didn't
love black people and I guess we came
off and I came back and I was like no
[ __ ] the Jewish media in the days that
followed Vogue and Balenciaga severed
ties with Kanye as did CAA the talent
agency that represents him a completed
documentary about the Grammy winner is
being shelved by Production Studio MRC
tons of celebs have spoken out
condemning anti-Semitism in light of
Kanye's recent rants including his ex
Kim Kardashian who tweeted on Monday
quote hate speech is never okay or
excusable I stand together with the
Jewish community and call on the
terrible violence and hateful rhetoric
towards them to come to an immediate end
we've been trying to move forward with
love and with prayer and we've literally
been finding out that
that isn't working Vivica A fox weighed
into ET over the weekend after
delivering a strongly worded message to
Kanye on an episode of her Fox Soul Talk
Show yo Kanye F you and I mean that with
everything inside of me so I thought
maybe a little extra tough love in there
that maybe that's what Kanye is missing
I believe more anything else he's
missing his mother somebody that would
say now boy you don't went too far and
remember this song
I'll be the king of me
[Music]
well you won't be able to hear it much
longer because The Chainsmokers
announced on Instagram they removed
their song named after Kanye from
streaming sites explaining quote eight
years ago we made a song back then this
guy inspired Us in so many ways with his
music and vision this is just not the
same guy we loved and were inspired by
which really saddens us I hope he gets
his [ __ ] together and stops with this
hate rhetoric and bullying before it's
too late
foreign